entre les convois agricoles les bottes
de paille les animaux de la ferme et les
stands de produits locaux
on pouvait trouver cette année pour le
66e festival de la terre la grande
nouveauté la course d'ânes on a mis en
place les courses d'ânes tout simple
dans un rayon avec un petit chariot suqi
d'arrière et puis ilan têtus comme il
est bas soit avant soit s'arrête face à
soi et ça a très très bien marché les
gens étaient heureux voilà c'était un
spectacle les ânes c'est vraiment
magnifique
un lieu de rencontre entre agriculteurs
producteurs et visiteurs
pour rachel qui vient pour la première
fois c'est l'opportunité de faire
découvrir à sa fille le milieu rural on
a fait le tour en tracteur m'ont tous
les jeux pour enfants on a participé à
assister
au moins pas au moins ça nous met là ils
font les balles de foin à l'ancienne on
a discuté avec les gens un festival pour
mettre en avant les agriculteurs du
territoire notamment pendant la pause
déjeuner où les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir de nouveaux produits du
terroir nous avons mis en place une
restauration issus des producteurs donc
nous avons proposé le comment dire le
fameux hamburger de poulet accompagné de
des frites donc frites de jérémy murray
à jumeaux ville et le poulet qui est
produit à son chant donc sur
l'exploitation
au total environ 15000 visiteurs étaient
présents ce week-end pour le festival de
la terre qui ne désemplit pas face à
l'engouement des yvelinois pour les
agriculteurs et producteurs locaux